PROFESSOR: This is Dr.
[? MATLAB, ?] lecture
5, scripts and functions.
The previous lecture we
saw the function FtoC that
converts Fahrenheit to Celsius.
Let's take another
look at that function.
Here it is.
It's a very simple function.
I've changed it
around a little bit,
but it accepts Fer as input.
Cel is output.
And this is how we write it.
I could have, of course,
written this as a script.
And it would have been
a much worse idea.
Let's try it as a script.
I'll comment this out.
And I'll comment this out.
And now if I save it, I can
change directory to Scripts.
I can say Fer equals 80
and now call my FtoC.
And now if I look at Cel,
it equals the answer.
The problem with this--
there are several
problems with this.
One is that I need to
understand the inner working,
my inner notation of the
script in order to use it.
I need to know that
Fer is an input.
Cel is the output.
So I need to know that
before I call the script,
I have to assign 80 into Fer.
After I call the script, I
get the answer inside Cel.
I need to know all of that.
And of course,
most functions are
going to be much
more complicated
than this one-liner.
Another problem is that,
obviously since it requires
me to write into Fer
and write into Cel,
it will overwrite Fer and Cel.
And particularly, it
will overwrite Cel.
So if I have an important number
in Cel and now I call FtoC,
this important number
is overwritten.
There's nothing I
can do about it.
Except for changing
this script, there's
no way I can make it
not overwrite Cel.
Now most functions
have all kinds
of intermediary variables.
So ind1 and there's
some assignment
that goes into it
there, and another one,
and so on, which are
needed for the calculation.
These are of course fake ones,
but imagine that you had these
and now you would call these.
Sorry, you would
call FtoC again.
You would be littered
by these variables
that you don't know
where they came from.
You don't care about
them because they're
some partial result
inside the script.
And also they might
have overwritten one
of your variables.
So this could be
really a disaster.
This is where
scoping is important.
When you put this
inside a function,
even if you keep all
the littering the same,
now you call this function--
let's clear my variables first.
Let's look who's here.
No one's here.
And now I'm going to
call FtoC with 80.
Again the answer, and the
only variable that exists,
is this automatic
variable called ans.
Ans is an automatic
variable that
is generated when a
value is returned,
but it's not assigned.
So for example, if I do 1
plus 2, there is also an ans.
And ans equals 3.
This is useful if, for example--
notice that here I forgot
to actually assign this
into a variable.
So I can now save it by
saying, x equals ans.
And now my answer
is saved into x.
Again, using functions does
not litter my work space
with partial results.
You see ind1, ind2 are
contained inside this function,
and we do not see them outside.
And they make it unnecessary
to know the inner workings
of the function.
I don't need to know what
the inner name of the input
variable is and what the inner
name of the output variable is.
I just need to know that FtoC
accepts an input variable
and returns a value.
I don't need to know the
name of those variables.
Scope also allows
us to write what's
called recursive functions.
A classic example of
recursive function
is the function that creates
the Fibonacci sequence.
So let's try this.
We already had one Fibonacci
so let's do Fibbo2.
And it accepts an n.
The base case, of course.
We need to return a value.
And if it's not less
than three, then
we need to return the sum of the
two lower Fibbonacci numbers.
This is a horrible way of
creating the Fibonacci sequence
because it involves an
exponentially large amount
of function calls.
But it works.
And the reason it works is
because the Fibbo in here,
the variables
inside it, are also
disconnected from the Fibbo
here and the Fibbo here.
All these functions are
called one inside the other,
but they don't
overwrite the variables.
So the v inside
the inner Fibbo is
different from the v inside
the outer Fibbo and so on.
So let me save this.
OK, so this works.
Now notice that if I try it
with 25, it takes a bit of time.
And 35 is almost
too long to run.
I'm not going to even
wait for this to run.
This is calling 2 to the power
35 function calls, which is
a little bit too many for me.
And I'm going to cancel
it-- ctrl c, cancel.
And you can see here--
let me show you the trace--
all the function calls
when it was stopped.
It was stopped here.
But this was called
from this line,
and this was called
and this was called from here.
This is all the same line
calling itself over and over
again, each time lowering n
by 1, until eventually n is 2.
And then it can
return the value.
It's that it keeps forgetting
the value of the Fibonacci
sequence when it needs it again.
To fix that, let us keep a
variable that will actually
hold the Fibonacci sequence.
So we initialize it with 1 1,
which is the starting point.
And now we will
call a helper file--
helper function, that is.
And we will return the
value that is needed.
The helper function will
guarantee that Fn is defined.
Let's see how we do this.
Here is the helper function.
It doesn't have any return
value, but it has an input.
And all it does is checks if
the number of elements in F
is less than 10.
And if it is, then it
calculates the required one.
So first it calls
helper with n minus 1,
and then it says that Fn equals
Fn minus 1, plus Fn minus 2.
And then it's done.
So the helper
function guarantees
that the Fibonacci
sequence is updated up
to n, this variable F, and then
we just return the one we need.
So by this way,
this assignment only
happens once for every n,
which makes it linear and end.
Now we don't need
all of this stuff.
The only thing we do
need is this final end.
Let me show you here.
We want this function here.
Sorry, we need another end.
We want this function here to
be embedded inside this function
because what that
does is it makes
this variable F visible
both for this function
and for this function.
So this F and this F
are the same variable.
And the hover text says so--
the scope of variable F
spans multiple functions.
So let's see how that works.
I'll save it.
We call Fibbo2 is 3 and
the answer is correct.
4, 5, and 35--
no problem, 45--
no problem, 55--
no problem.
This is a simple
example of what's
called dynamic programming.
And this is a way of reducing
an exponential recursive
implementation
into a linear one.
Now, you can have more
than one input variable,
and you can have
more than one output.
But I suggest that you
investigate that on your own.